Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会直接赢取Lisa提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for tuning in and I hope you'll find today's episode really useful as ever. Today we are thinking about something which is going to be useful for you probably regardless of what your current role is. So it is clinical notes, we're talking about clinical notes and whatever role you're doing if you're working with people it's likely that there's some element of note taking. So in case you don't know what clinical notes are, I thought I'd give you a little bit of an overview of that to begin with. So when we are working with people, we have certain responsibilities and safeguarding actions that we have to take to keep people safe. But also it's useful for us
我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。非常感谢大家的收听，希望你们能像往常一样觉得今天的节目非常有用。今天我们要讨论的话题，无论你目前从事什么职位，可能都会对你有帮助。那就是临床记录，我们正在谈论临床记录。无论你从事什么角色，只要你与人打交道，很可能都会涉及某种形式的笔记记录。所以，如果你不知道什么是临床记录，我想先做一个简单的概述。当我们与人合作时，我们承担着一定的责任和保障行动，以确保人们的安全。但同时，这对我们来说也很有用，
to be able to log and discuss what has happened in the contacts, especially if that involves risk. And that's so that other members of the multidisciplinary team can see what's going on if there's a crisis call, for for example or if there's other members of the team involved or if for example you were to go off on sick leave it would be useful to know what had been happening in your sessions. So the main function of clinical notes is similar to supervision is client safety and also your own protection for you to be sort of legally and professionally saying what has happened in a session. So how often do we need to be writing them? When do we write
能够记录并讨论接触中发生的事情，特别是如果涉及风险的话。这样，多学科团队的其他成员如果遇到危机电话，或者有其他团队成员参与，或者如果你休病假，他们就能知道你的会谈中发生了什么。因此，临床记录的主要功能与督导类似，是为了客户安全，也是为了你自己的保护，让你在法律和专业层面上说明会谈中发生了什么。那么我们需要多久写一次呢？我们什么时候写？
them? How do we write them? Those are all of the questions we're going to be covering today. So in answer to how and when we write them it might well be that you need to follow the guidance laid out by whichever employer you're working for. So for example I think when I was working in an NHS trust most recently, they asked you to get it done within 48 hours, I think. I often found and still find that I am more likely to get it done within the appropriate timeframes if I do it right after the session. So I'm very much still a fan of a 50 minute clinical hour. And then I use the remaining 10 minutes to write my notes and get that done. I find that if I push it or delay it, or for some other reason need to dash out and do something else or get distracted or want a cup of tea, then yeah, it's less likely to happen in that timely manner within that day.
我们怎么写？这些都是我们今天要涵盖的问题。关于如何以及何时撰写，你可能需要遵循你所任职的雇主制定的指导方针。例如，我想我最近在NHS信托工作时，他们要求在48小时内完成。我经常发现，如果我在会谈结束后立即完成，更有可能在适当的时间内完成。所以我仍然非常推崇50分钟的临床小时，然后利用剩下的10分钟来写笔记并完成它。我发现如果我拖延，或者因为其他原因需要匆忙去做别的事情，或者分心，或者想喝杯茶，那么在当天及时完成的可能性就会降低。
And of course, our memories are fallible. So I would say where possible, and obviously where your job plan allows, it's useful to get it done between sessions. And I guess thinking about how you write notes as well can be useful so it might be that you've got a trust phone or a trust tablet and that you can scribble your notes down on that between sessions it might be that you do paper notes still I know that some services still do that or it might be that you have to report your notes by entering them into a specific system. In the past, I've used EPEX, CareNotes and Rio. And yeah, you can't always access all of those systems from remote things like phones. But it might be worth saying that you might be able to, if you've got secure encrypted devices, such as, you know, a phone that's been given to you by your trust,
当然，我们的记忆是不可靠的。所以我想说，在可能的情况下，并且在你的工作计划允许的情况下，在会谈之间完成它很有用。我想思考你如何写笔记也很有用，可能你有一个信托机构提供的手机或平板电脑，你可以在会谈间隙在上面草草记下笔记；可能你仍然使用纸质笔记，我知道有些服务仍然这样做；或者你可能必须通过输入特定的系统来报告你的笔记。过去，我使用过EPEX、CareNotes和Rio。是的，你并不总是能从手机等远程设备访问所有这些系统。但值得一提的是，如果你有安全的加密设备，比如信托机构给你的手机，
that you could use the note facility to write your notes in there so that you can access them later so that you're using the time you do have in a timely way so yeah don't do anything that's not trust compliant so if your trust doesn't allow you to do that then don't do that but I'm always thinking about ways that I can maximize the time that I'm doing so that I'm not repeating things or so that I'm using snippets of time that I've got. So yeah, have a look at your job, have a look at your job plan and see what might make that work for you. We're going to be going through some top tips for what to include in your clinical notes and how to do it in a way that makes them robust and user-friendly hopefully you know it's likely that in some cases no one will read them you know so if you hold
你可以使用笔记功能在里面写笔记，这样以后就可以访问它们，从而有效地利用你拥有的时间。所以，不要做任何不符合信托规定的事情，如果你的信托不允许这样做，那就不要做。但我一直在思考如何最大化我的时间，这样我就不会重复工作，或者利用我拥有的时间碎片。所以，看看你的工作，看看你的工作计划，看看什么能让你行得通。我们将介绍一些关于临床记录中应包含的内容以及如何以稳健且用户友好的方式进行记录的顶级技巧。希望你知道，在某些情况下可能没人会读它们，你知道，如果你持有
your own clinical responsibility then you know maybe no one will read them unless they get called by a court or they get requested by the client themselves and then you'll have the fun of redacting anything that you can't share with the patient which is where you go through with a big thick black marker pen anything that can't be shared so for example if they've been in a group and you've mentioned the actions of another group member even if you don't mention the group member's name you can't put that in because that relates to another client you've got to like scrub that out um so yeah redacting is very fun when you get a request for that either from a court or from the client themselves and you then have to look through years and years of notes that may not even be your own if the person has left the service. So I hope you don't experience that, but you probably are likely to at some point in your career. So be aware of that
自己的临床责任，那么可能没人会读它们，除非它们被法院传唤或客户本人要求查看，那时你就会体验到涂黑（redacting）那些不能与患者分享的内容的乐趣了。你需要用一支粗大的黑色记号笔涂掉任何不能分享的内容。例如，如果他们在小组中，你提到了其他小组成员的行为，即使你不提那个成员的名字，你也不能把它写进去，因为它涉及另一个客户，你必须把它涂掉。所以，当你收到法院或客户本人的请求时，涂黑是非常有趣的，你必须翻阅多年来可能甚至不是你自己的笔记，如果那个人已经离开了服务。所以我希望你不要经历这种情况，但你职业生涯中的某个时刻很可能会遇到。所以要意识到
term redacting, because it might well crop up for you. So yes, if you are a trainee listening to this, then it's likely that you don't hold clinical responsibility for your own client work yet. That would usually, as far as I'm aware, that would be held by your clinical supervisor. And similarly, if you're doing forensic or health, that would still be held by the qualified psychologist above you. So my first top tip is always speak to your supervisor. So if you're an assistant psychologist, you also don't hold clinical responsibility. But if you're a qualified PWP, I believe that you would hold your own clinical responsibility. So nobody would be needing necessarily to cross-check your notes whereas I have worked in services where my notes have needed to sort of be secondarily signed so
“涂黑”这个术语，因为它很可能会出现在你的工作中。所以，是的，如果你是一名正在听这个节目的实习生，那么你很可能还没有持有自己客户工作的临床责任。据我所知，这通常由你的临床督导持有。同样，如果你从事法医或健康心理学，这仍然由你上面的合格心理学家持有。所以我的第一个顶级技巧是始终与你的督导沟通。所以，如果你是一名助理心理学家，你也不持有临床责任。但如果你是一名合格的PWP（心理健康从业者），我相信你会持有自己的临床责任。所以没有人需要交叉检查你的笔记，而我曾经工作过的服务机构中，我的笔记需要被二次签名，所以
you will need to check in with your individual trust requirements and also what is safe and ethical practice for the role that you are in. Another reason that you need to speak to your supervisor is because all supervisors will have different standards and expectations for the way that they like to see clinical notes written and what feels good enough for them. So even if I reference my six different placements that I did on training, all of them had a very different vibe to them and very different expectations. So what was right for number one most certainly wouldn't have been right for number six. specifically was a psychodynamic placement and of course they believe in very detailed notes and also keeping something called process notes too as well as formulations so the process for clinical notes was very different than
你需要核对你所在信托机构的个人要求，以及你所处角色的安全和道德实践。你需要与督导沟通的另一个原因是，所有督导对临床记录的撰写方式以及对他们来说什么是“足够好”都有不同的标准和期望。所以即使我参考了我在培训期间做的六个不同的实习，它们都有非常不同的氛围和期望。所以对第一个实习来说是正确的，对第六个来说肯定是不正确的。特别是有一个心理动力学实习，当然他们相信非常详细的笔记，并且除了案例构思外，还要保留所谓的“过程笔记”。所以临床记录的过程与
it was for example when I was working with adults and similarly when we're working with children we might need to make even more thorough notes to be just ensuring that we're sticking to safeguarding practices and reporting on anything that could potentially lead to a risk. top tips is something that I only discovered when I was newly qualified and that is if you are making a decision or if you have had support to make a decision then you should record that in the notes but you should also justify how you've come to that decision. So if that's as part of a multidisciplinary team meeting or discussion with your supervisor, you need to be evidencing the rationale for that decision making process. Because if you just write what the decision is, then it's a bit ambiguous about how you got there. But it's a bit like in maths when you were doing maths at school if you show your workings then it's clearer in a court of law should you need to justify what you're justifying so always be able to back up why you're suggesting something if you are
例如我与成年人工作时的情况非常不同。同样，当我们与儿童工作时，我们可能需要做更详尽的笔记，以确保我们坚持保障实践，并报告任何可能导致风险的事情。顶级技巧是我在刚获得资格时才发现的，那就是如果你正在做出决定，或者如果你在支持下做出了决定，你应该将其记录在笔记中，但你也应该证明你是如何得出该决定的。所以如果这是作为多学科团队会议或与督导讨论的一部分，你需要证明该决策过程的依据。因为如果你只写决定是什么，那么你是如何得出这个结论的就有点模糊了。但这有点像你在学校做数学题时，如果你展示了你的计算过程，那么在法庭上如果你需要证明你的理由，就会更清楚。所以如果你被要求这样做，一定要能够支持你建议某事的原因。
asked to do it but I sometimes think if I was called to a court and the judge asked me to justify something, unless it's written down, I can't. I can't just say, well, I was holding that in mind because that's not legally robust. So anything related to risk and decision making needs to be in your notes. So let's take a brief break here and then I'll be back along with my next top tips. from so many things that you can try the aspiring psychologist the aspiring psychologist welcome back uh thank you for sticking with me i hope you love the jingle so um yes what i do with my clinical notes these days is that i will document the session number and that might well include um of how many planned sessions as well so it might be eight of twenty for example once you don't know how many sessions are going to be I
但我有时想，如果我被传唤到法庭，法官让我证明某事，除非它被写下来，否则我做不到。我不能只是说，嗯，我把它记在心里了，因为那在法律上是不稳健的。所以任何与风险和决策相关的内容都需要在你的笔记中。让我们在这里休息一下，然后我会带着我的下一个顶级技巧回来。欢迎回来，谢谢你的坚持，希望你喜欢这段音乐。所以，是的，我这些天处理临床记录的方式是，我会记录会谈次数，这可能包括计划的会谈次数，例如20次中的第8次。一旦你不知道会有多少次会谈，我
would just write what the session number was and obviously whether it was attended or not also I would document whether it was attended on time and if not what what the reasons for that were might have been my own absence my own leagueness but yes it doesn't happen so much in private practice I don't think it's happened ever actually but certainly when I was in NHS services or other other employed services sometimes it was my responsibility that I was I kept a client waiting so I would kind of go through the main points but not in an exhaustive fashion so the main points covered and if there were any pertinent discussion points within that I would
只会写下会谈次数，显然还有是否出席。我还会记录是否准时出席，如果没有，原因是什么。可能是因为我自己的缺席或迟到，但是的，这种情况在私人执业中发生得不多，我想实际上从未发生过。但当然，当我在NHS服务或其他受雇服务中时，有时是因为我的责任导致客户等待，所以我通常会过一遍要点，但不是详尽无遗的。所以涵盖的要点，以及其中是否有任何相关的讨论点，我会
put those in almost as a bullet point kind of section so we discussed yada yada yada you know that sort of thing but it was not it's not exhaustive um i do not work in a psychodynamic way currently so it's not everything i can remember about a session of course we need to make sure that we've got any elements in there that are related to risk or safeguarding so if there there's an open safeguarding case going on for the client that you're working with or someone immediately in their life that they are kind of responsible for,
把它们几乎作为项目符号部分放进去，比如我们讨论了什么什么，你知道那种事情，但它不是详尽的。我目前不是以心理动力学的方式工作，所以当然不是我能记住的关于会谈的一切。我们需要确保我们在其中包含任何与风险或保障相关的内容。所以如果和你一起工作的客户或他们生活中直接负责的某人有一个正在进行的开放式保障案例，
then we need to be having that discussion and revisiting that and documenting any changes with relation to safeguarding or any updates in there. And similarly, if there's any elements of risk and any elements of sort of risk taking, then you need to be evidencing that and you need to be evidencing if there's a plan to manage that risk, which might well link back to any care plan or risk plan that's been done either with you in conjunction with you or with other members of the team or psychiatry. I will also cover any agreed action points so if there's homework or own work to be done or things
那么我们需要进行讨论并重新审视，并记录与保障相关的任何变化或其中的任何更新。同样，如果有任何风险因素和某种冒险行为的因素，那么你需要证明这一点，并且你需要证明是否有管理该风险的计划，这可能与你与团队其他成员或精神科医生共同制定的任何护理计划或风险计划相关联。我还会涵盖任何商定的行动点，所以如果有家庭作业或需要完成的个人工作，或者客户说他们将努力去做的事情，
that the client said they were going to strive to do then they will be they will be noted down so that if and when I need to review those before seeing the client for the next session I'm quickly up to speed with with what we're what we're striving for what we're aiming for and what we'd agreed and it's not necessarily as a way of you know checking up on them but it's thinking about you know I wonder how how you got on with that and what's that been like for you and is there anything you know new or different since we met last time that can be a really nice way of exploring that area without making people feel like they're being checked up on and then I would write the next session date and that's pretty much it so they're not super long like I said they're 50 minute sessions.
那么它们会被记录下来，以便如果我在下次会谈前需要回顾这些内容，我可以快速了解我们正在努力实现的目标以及我们商定的内容。这不一定是为了检查他们，而是思考，我想知道你做得怎么样，这对你来说感觉如何，自从我们上次见面以来有什么新的或不同的事情吗？这可以成为探索该领域的一种非常好的方式，而不会让人觉得他们正在被检查。然后我会写下下次会谈的日期，基本上就是这样。所以它们不是超级长，就像我说的，它们是50分钟的会谈。
And if there's EMDR that I've done, then there will be separate paper free paperwork now because I've been using the Remarkable 2 tablet that I really like. So I will talk about that in a moment. But yeah, there's extra paperwork there. So I would also report that separate EMDR paperwork has been made and will be added to the file. So let's have a little think about this remarkable tablet that I've got. So I've used it to plan today's podcast episode. You might not have heard of a paper free tablet. So it's called is called a a remarkable two and it comes with um actually i don't think it does come with it i think you have to buy it separately so i bought this pen separately and it's got a nice little rubber on the end and you can rub stuff out but what i like about it
如果我做了EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工），那么现在会有单独的无纸化文书工作，因为我一直在使用我非常喜欢的Remarkable 2平板电脑。所以我稍后会谈到这一点。但是的，那里有额外的文书工作。所以我也会报告已经制作了单独的EMDR文书工作，并将被添加到文件中。让我们来思考一下我拥有的这个Remarkable平板电脑。我用它来规划今天的播客节目。你可能没听说过无纸化平板电脑。它叫Remarkable 2，它配有……实际上我不认为它配有它，我想你必须单独购买，所以我单独买了这支笔，它末端有一个很好的小橡皮擦，你可以擦掉东西。但我喜欢它的是
is that so for example for the first time yesterday um i made supervision notes on it and then I can quickly send those as a PDF via email or through a few clicks of the button to send it to myself. And then I can just upload that to the client's clinical notes and make a note that the supervision notes have been have been added so again you'd need to check what was trust compliant but I'm always thinking about how to maximize the time that I've got so I found that I like supervision I enjoy that process but then having to write separate notes for it afterwards especially when I'm now in private practice I don't get paid for that time just felt a bit frustrating so that's where I'm really liking this paper free tablet because everything happens within the session and then I it just saves automatically and then I can just do it with a quick few clicks and save so if you think that might work for you then you could well discuss
例如，昨天我第一次在上面做了督导笔记，然后我可以快速通过电子邮件或点击几个按钮将其作为PDF发送给自己。然后我就可以直接把它上传到客户的临床记录中，并注明督导笔记已经添加。所以同样，你需要检查什么符合信托规定，但我一直在思考如何最大化我拥有的时间。所以我发现我喜欢督导，我享受那个过程，但之后必须为它写单独的笔记，特别是当我现在在私人执业时，我没有得到那段时间的报酬，这感觉有点令人沮丧。这就是我非常喜欢这个无纸化平板电脑的原因，因为一切都在会谈中发生，然后它会自动保存，然后我只需快速点击几下就可以保存。所以如果你认为这可能对你有用，那么你完全可以讨论
that with your supervisor or your manager. I did try initially to try and get on board with that happening with an iPad but I could not get it to do what I wanted to do and for it to remain as functional. So what I like about the Remarkable is that I can go back into the notes, they can stay handwritten or I can have little bits appear in typed text to help it stand out more. I can draw my family trees on there, which I really like to do. So yeah, when I was buying my Remarkable, I couldn't find any discount codes
与你的督导或经理讨论。我最初确实尝试过用iPad来实现这一点，但我无法让它做我想做的事情，也无法让它保持同样的功能。所以我喜欢Remarkable的地方在于我可以回到笔记中，它们可以保持手写，或者我可以有一些小的打字文本出现，以帮助它更突出。我可以在上面画我的家谱，我非常喜欢这样做。所以是的，当我购买我的Remarkable时，我找不到任何折扣代码，
and that was frustrating to me. But I have got a $40 off code if you do want to try it out. There's 100 day quibble free returns as well so if that is something you think might help you in terms of your organization because you can save everything in separate folders and it all can be password protected and all of that jazz so yes if you think that's something that would be useful then do think about yeah getting yourself a tablet and there will be details in the show notes or you can send me a dm
这让我感到沮丧。但我有一个40美元的优惠码，如果你想尝试一下的话。还有100天的无忧退货政策，所以如果这是你认为在组织方面能帮助你的东西，因为你可以把所有东西保存在单独的文件夹中，并且都可以设置密码保护等等。所以是的，如果你认为这会很有用，那么一定要考虑给自己买一个平板电脑，节目说明中会有详细信息，或者你可以给我发私信，
if you want that coupon code to get 40 off which i would have loved because i could not find any coupon codes anywhere when i was doing it so i would say it transforms my practice and i'm going to look at whether i can implement it into my clinical notes with clients. The only difficulty being is I don't currently write clinical notes in sessions because I find it sometimes takes away something about what I'm doing with the client so I'd need to think quite carefully about the way that I do that especially as I'm being paid for that time by the client. But yeah, I want to think about how I can do that in a way that suits my needs and doesn't take from
如果你想要那个优惠券代码来获得40美元的折扣，我当时会非常喜欢的，因为我在做这件事时到处都找不到任何优惠券代码。所以我会说它改变了我的实践，我正在考虑是否可以将其应用到我与客户的临床记录中。唯一的困难是我目前不在会谈中写临床记录，因为我发现它有时会带走我与客户互动的一些东西，所以我需要非常仔细地考虑我这样做的方式，特别是考虑到客户正在为那段时间付费。但是的，我想思考如何以一种适合我需求且不损害
the client and their session. So yeah, I would love any thoughts you've got about how you do your clinical notes and whether you found this episode useful, whether it's raised any thoughts for you really whether you are the sort of person that likes to write really long notes whether you're all about the brevity you know because we're all individually different but it might be that you're very much led by what your current supervisor's requirements are what I found is especially once, you can take the bits from certain jobs or placements that you do like. And anything that doesn't work for you doesn't sit. You can leave behind when you leave. And then so long as you're following the guidance of any new supervisor until you're qualified, you can pretty much do what you like, what works for you. Because you're allowed to develop your own personal style and flair as well
客户及其会谈的方式来做到这一点。所以是的，我很乐意听到你关于如何处理临床记录的任何想法，以及你是否觉得这一集有用，它是否真的引发了你的任何思考，无论你是那种喜欢写很长笔记的人，还是那种追求简洁的人，因为我们每个人都是不同的。但可能你非常受你当前督导的要求所引导。我发现的是，特别是当你能从你喜欢的某些工作或实习中汲取精华。任何对你不起作用、不适合你的东西，当你离开时都可以抛在脑后。只要你在获得资格之前遵循任何新督导的指导，你基本上可以做任何你喜欢的事情，任何对你有效的事情。因为你也被允许发展自己的个人风格和天赋，
so if you would welcome more advice and guidance about so many different topics we've also got stuff coming up in the membership about logical and deductive reasoning which i know is a big part of some declinci testing processes so we've got a session happening on that to help develop confidence so by the time you listen to this it will have happened but you'd be able to access that on replay if that is something that you feel would be useful for you and to develop your confidence and competence in that area. We've also got loads of other stuff in there. We've got seven or eight months worth of CBT teaching that you can work through. We've got loads of stuff on reflective practice.
所以如果你欢迎关于许多不同主题的更多建议和指导，我们在会员区也有关于逻辑和演绎推理的内容，我知道这是某些临床测试过程的重要组成部分。所以我们有一个关于这个的会议来帮助建立信心，所以当你听到这个的时候它已经发生了，但如果你觉得这对你有用，并且想在该领域发展你的信心和能力，你将能够通过回放来访问它。我们在那里还有很多其他东西。我们有七八个月的CBT教学内容，你可以学习。我们有很多关于反思实践的内容。
It's just a good place to hang out. It's a really, really nice supportive group of people so do check out the aspiring psychologist membership which you can join for 30 pounds a month which also gets you access to the back catalogue and you can leave um you know whenever time suits you for more information on that do check out the show notes or um my socials and yeah it will be available via my bio links there's information about the membership do also please come along and join the free group on facebook which is the aspiring psychologist community brackets free group i think he says my name and so on dr marianne trent or come and connect with me on all of my social channels I am now Dr. Marianne Trent and I love helping you celebrate your wins and hearing what you think to the
这是一个很好的交流场所。这是一个非常非常好的支持性群体，所以一定要看看“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划，你可以每月支付30英镑加入，这也可以让你访问过往目录，你可以在任何适合你的时间离开。欲了解更多信息，请查看节目说明或我的社交媒体，是的，它将通过我的个人资料链接提供。有关于会员资格的信息，也请一定要来加入Facebook上的免费群组，即“有抱负的心理学家社区（免费群组）”，我想他说了我的名字等等，Dr. Marianne Trent，或者在我的所有社交频道上与我联系。我现在是Marianne Trent博士，我喜欢帮助你庆祝你的胜利，并听听你对
content that I produce so again thank you so much for listening thank you for being part of my world and wishing you a lovely day whatever you're up to take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different
我制作的内容的看法。所以再次非常感谢你的收听，感谢你成为我世界的一部分，祝你度过愉快的一天，无论你在做什么，保重。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将在成为合格心理学家的道路上。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有多少不同的
routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
途径可以达到目标，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。